thank you Mr Speaker uh I'm very sorry
that the sequencing uh that we chose was
not to your satisfaction I was a
order order order
that is totally not acceptable not
the true State I don't want
I think we need to understand each other
I am the defender of this house and
these benches on both sides I am not
going to be spoken to by a Secretary of
State who is absolutely not accept my
ruling take it with good grace
and accept it that members should hear
it first not a WMS or what you decide
these members have been elected by their
constituents and they have the right to
hear it first and it is time this
government recognized we're all elected
we're all moves upon and use the correct
manners Secretary of State